à odessa le nombre de morts et de
blessés ne cesse d'augmenter après qu'un
missile a touché un immeuble résidentiel
de neuf étages ainsi qu'un camp de
vacances qui se trouvait juste à côté
parmi les victimes il y avait notamment
des enfants une femme enceinte aussi a
été blessé cette attaque elle fait écho
à l'intensification des frappes contre
des infrastructures civiles depuis une
semaine dans des villes qui se trouvent
en dehors de la ligne de front à qui il
crée mentchouk nikolaïev ou encore râle
qu'yves la situation est souvent la même
des quartiers résidentiels sont touchés
par des missiles la nuit ou très tôt le
matin de quoi rajouter de l'anxiété pour
une population qui rentrent aujourd'hui
dans son 128e jours de guerre côté
ukrainien on dénonce une stratégie de la
terreur les autorités russes elles ont
déjà nié par le passé avoir visé des
lieux de vie de civils le porte parole
de l'administration militaire d'odessa a
déclaré que les missiles avaient été
tirés par des avions depuis la mer noire
cette attaque elle arrive au lendemain
d'un moment clé pour les troupes
l'ukrainienne le retrait des forces
russes de l'îlot stratégique de l'île
aux serpents qui se trouve à une
trentaine de kilomètres d'odessa